the reason why i like kevin samuels and
how he would call out black women is
because
i'm puerto rican and so we have like
similar problems where we're out here
absolutely prepared to curse out and
fight men and then complaining that
we're single meanwhile our kids suffer
because of it and like me as a minority
woman i'm like no way like i can figure
this out so i had to learn how to not be
argumentative like i was when i was
first with my my husband we were dating
like it took a long time for me to stop
being rude because that was my baseline
and i had already done some work on it
okay so this is like really sad
that i i did work to be less rude just
to be like eh you need to do more but
that i don't talk anything i did not
talk any differently than the women in
my family that came before me i thought
it was normal and i didn't know that
when you disrespect men they don't feel
love but once i figured that out i was
like well that's not nice yeah i'm like
okay well i wanted to feel like i love
him